in the very south of poland near the
slovak border you'll find impressive
mountain landscapes
this is the world of mountain guide
pyotr konopka
he has climbed peaks all over the world
in the andes the himalayas
the rockies
but his favorite mountain is right here
in the high tatras it's called
rizzi
the tatara are probably the lowest range
of mountains in the world
the landscape has the feel of serious
tall mountains but in fact the highest
peak is just 2655 meters
konopka has been guiding visitors here
professionally for more than 30 years
in his free time he loves to go climbing
it's all very accessible there are
well-equipped huts in every valley
and the views are good
andrei wapsa also enjoys the views as he
pilots tourists around the high tetras
it is harder flying in the mountains
because the weather keeps changing all
the time
today for example it is really windy and
there's lots of turbulence
but all the challenges are offset by the
amazing views
zakopane is a famous resort for winter
sports
nearby is coho the village is famous for
its many traditional wooden houses from
the 19th century
the village has had landmark status for
more than 50 years
croco wolf is on the charney dunayas
river which feeds into the donnayats
river
a great way to explore the region is by
raft
the tradition of rafting grew out of
lagging timber was sent down the dunayas
into the vistula
and then all the way to the baltic later
goods were transported by raft and
nowadays people are
where the dunyach flows into georgeton
lake stands nizitza castle
it was built in the 14th century by a
hungarian nobleman
for centuries it served as a border post
between poland and hungary
one of the attractions is a well 60
meters deep
there is a legend about this well brun
hilde and bogaswav once lived in this
castle
they fought a lot and one day in anger
bogaswav threw brunhilda down the well
she came back to haunt him as a ghost
but she eventually
now both of them are said to haunt the
castle
we now head north away from the
mountains to bochnia a town famous for
its salt mine
the mine began operations in the 13th
century mining ended in the late 20th
century
some of the galleries and chambers deep
below the surface are now open to
visitors
last year unesco declared the mine a
world heritage site
mukash pannek is a tour guide he knows
all the old legends about the mine
this is our salt garden it often drips
here
and if a drop of water lands on your
head it will make you cleverer
if it lands on your outstretched hand
you'll become rich
but if it lands on your neck or back
you'll have to toil
and you'll become a hunchback
meanwhile andrei wapsa is on his last
tour of the day
i think about flying every day and i
always want to be up in the sky
it is so wonderful
especially when you're flying above the
beautiful landscapes of southern poland
you